I actually just got my fade redone as
far as coming from a haircut oh you did
I had to who does your hair uh his
name's Calvin he uh he cuts a lot of the
Titans players and so I met him through
uh one of the guys and now he just cuts
me on my buddy's hair fantastic is he
yeah North Nashville oh wow yeah he
really gets on there huh oh yeah High
bald fade damn he's good at it yeah I
just got my hair cut today too actually
oh look at us that's crazy this girl
Whitney Cuts mine here in Nashville
um have you ever anyone mess up your
haircut like really bad oh dude one time
my freaking friend's dad first of all
never get your hair cut in um
Mississippi
okay thank you just don't do it I mean
yeah sure even if it's at the mall the
casino it doesn't matter
dude I got a haircut at a casino one
time bro dude I'll tell you what this is
crazy so yeah one time Chris Pratt
actually one time this is and I'm kind
of name-dropping but this is whatever he
sent me a DM he asked me to be on a
movie of his right so I went through all
these things and got like got the got
the he helped me get the part in the
movie and then I got this horrible
haircut
and it made and we're just about to like
start taping and I also didn't uh I
didn't like the part was very small and
it was going to take like 12 weeks to do
oh yeah and I was like man this is just
it's a lot it's a lot and but what
capped it off was that day I had gotten
I'd had a show that weekend somewhere
and I got my hair cut in a casino in
Mississippi and it was so [__] bad it
pushed me over the edge I was like I
know I don't yeah I definitely want to
be on camera I don't want to be around
anyone I'm out yeah and this lady just
gotten out of like she went through like
this hair cutting rehabilitation program
through prison or whatever which I'm all
about like who cut your hair yeah good
for you man yeah that's what I was
thinking I was like God wants me here
this is what we're doing it was oh God I
wanted a [__] rope I should have gone
to prison on that on that lady it was
[__] bad dude and if I ever see that
[__] lady again somewhere you want to
go to casino Mississippi it was so bad
dude I was like I gamble I gambled with
my most valuable asset too so my hair
got to a point where it was so it was
getting caught in my shoulder pads and
so I just went to a barber and what I've
realized now is that when you have long
hair you need to go to a salon and like
work with someone who knows how to cut
long hair yeah I just went to a barber
and I swear to God he gave me a bowl cut
without putting a bowl on my head he'd
let my hair down and he just cut a
circle around my head and I looked at
and I was like
that's tough for me it's really tough
and I had to go to a salon literally
like an hour later and they had to like
fix it for him but it was still a brutal
he just went scissors in a circle it
hurts huh ah it really it was a struggle
for me my wife looked at me she was like
what is wrong with you I was like a lot
of things at this moment actually I
gotta leave yeah I've been neutered yeah
dude that's what it feels like oh dude
people don't know once you've grown like
like there's something about like why I
could see why Native Americans would go
and take the scalp of a man because it
was like the most powerful [__] thing
you could do it's very disrespectful did
you ever get a haircut like uh like
during coven like did anyone like I had
a guy I had a traveling Barber who I met
through a person through a person like
in Nashville that's a homeless guy dude
he showed up and I asked him if her fade
and he cut it and then he was on the
back of my neck and he was talking to me
and he was a football fan so he was
talking and you know like when you know
somebody messes something up and they
try to hide it and like it was like this
and I was like he stopped for like two
seconds I was like you good he's like
yeah no nothing's wrong I go in and I
show my wife and he basically put a
lightning bolt as my neckline oh it was
absolutely brutal why did he do it he
was just not paying attention oh yeah he
was asking a football question and he
just got excited it was hilarious I
looked I was like you know what man just
thank you for the time yeah and I'm
gonna call it a day oh my goodness
there's nothing worse than getting a bad
haircut man it's brutal it just ruins
your whole day maybe a week oh yeah it
can ruin even more at least you're
married Bro dude think yes it helps a
lot God you have yeah you know a lady
still likes you when you [__] get
home yes imagine you get a shitty
haircut then you go home and it says
just staring in the mirror like oh my
God I can't leave the house they're
trying on different hats and [__] you're
like
you suddenly become a beanie guy you
know Theo why are you wearing a beanie
don't worry about it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one